jennifer lopez and ben affleck enjoyed a
fun family night out to kick off their
weekend and just gonna try to enjoy
every minute stay present the couple
took their kids and ben's mom to see a
performance of hamilton on friday night
at the contagious theater in hollywood
of benefer holding hands were taken
outside the venue in the snaps j.lo was
seen wearing a ruffled floral dress
which she paired with a green jacket and
pink velvet heels as for ben he wore a
navy button-up shirt a dark blue jacket
and beige slacks with brown shoes it
feels really good and it's really nice
jen and ben are no strangers to a little
pda
[Music]
the two were recently spotted kissing
outside ben's brentwood home i'm
thrilled but i'm really happy so happy
that the couple were also looking at
million dollar homes together yeah i'm
ready i'm excited about it ben and jen
have done more family bonding this
summer too including taking their kids
to universal studios and celebrated the
oscar winners 49th birthday together jen
took the time to acknowledge the actor's
two daughters fifteen-year-old violet
and twelve-year-old seraphina whom he
shares with ex-wife jennifer gardner a
source previously told et that the
hustlers star picked out gifts for the
girls necklaces featuring their birth
flowers it was worth it and ben has been
spending some quality time with her
kiddos too jen shares 13 year old twins
max and emmy with her ex hubby marc
anthony and the source told et earlier
this month that jen ben and emmy had a
fun family night out at ellie hot spot
craigs while everyone was getting along
bonding adding that they all seemed
happy to be there of course the couple
famously known as benifer recently
rekindled their romance 17 years after
they called it quits
following her split from alex rodriguez
in april
et sat down with a former pro baseball
player who says despite facing several
high-profile setbacks including his
split from j-lo he's focusing on all the
positive things in his life right now i
had uh five years of an incredible
life and and partnership and also with
my daughters we learned so much and now
we have an opportunity to take that and
move forward and say you know what we're
so grateful for the last five years how
do we make the next five years better
because of lessons learned so i'm in a
great place i'm so grateful for where
god in in
in in the light has really put me in and
i'm really looking forward
mostly to see how my girls keep
developing
[Music]